there's too much debate about
what's the difference between vision and
mission right there's no standardized
definitions of these things
some people have one of them some people
have both of them nobody is
sure which one goes first uh
and i'm not willing to step into that
debate i think it's silly um
and so i i i believe in the just cause
which is this affirmative statement of a
future state that does not yet exist
that i will commit my business to help
build right
you can call it vision if you want but i
like the term just cause
because it holds a higher standard it's
a cause so just
that i would be willing to sacrifice for
it sacrifice could mean
um turning down a client that's free
money it could
because they don't believe what i
believe sacrifice could mean spending
time away from my family
it could mean taking business trips it
could mean turning down a job somewhere
else that could pay me more money
because i want to
do this i believe in this
and if any of you have vision statements
for your businesses
if you have a just cause a cause a cause
suggests
that your people would sacrifice for it
i have a test it's a very simple test of
three things
that if you can pass all these three
things you have a vision you have a just
cause worthy
of gay playing in the infinite game
right
so i'll run through them quickly and
i'll explain them your
vision your just cause must be
resilient it must be inclusive
and it must be service oriented okay so
resilient means
that your vision your just cause can
withstand
cultural political or technological
change
right which means when i hear people say
to be the best technology
well that's not going to sustain through
technological change think about how
many businesses went like this
simply because the internet was invented
right so
it has to your cause has to be written
in terms that is durable that is
is resilient through technological
political and uh
and cultural change that's number one
number two it has to be inclusive
which means it's the very words that you
choose
are an invitation to those who believe
what you believe
whether they're internal or external
right uh they're an invitation to anyone
who wants to contribute to what you
believe
so for example if you talk about um uh
to build the best travel website let's
just say
right um that means the only people who
would want to volunteer to be a part of
it
are people who build travel websites or
people who build websites that means if
you're an accountant if you're somebody
in back office if you're somewhere in
support
you've literally made me feel like a
second class citizen in my own company
right so it has to be written in terms
that anybody no matter what
job they play feels like they could
contribute directly to that cause
so it has to be inclusive and the the
third one is my favorite one
is it has to be service oriented in all
relationships there's always a
benefactor and a contributor a
contributor a benefactor
so if i go to my boss for advice uh
career advice
i expect that her advice to me will be
will benefit me
right i want to be the benefactor of
that contribution if they're giving me
advice
if she only gives me advice that
benefits her career right well that
means the primary benefit of her advice
was her not me so service orientation
means that the primary benefit goes
to those other than the contributor
so if you're the leader that means the
primary business of benefit of
leadership
has to go to those other than the leader
themselves you cannot make decisions
to enrich yourself you have to make
decisions to help those
uh that you lead now you absolutely can
make money you can absolutely have
ambition
those things are fine but not as the
primary benefit
right a salesperson cannot make a sale
simply
to drive their own bonus they have to
make the sale to help the person get
what they're trying to buy
the primary benefit if you're an
investor the primary benefit of your
investment
the primary benefit of your investment
has to go to someone other than yourself
i.e the company you're investing in and
if you're the company the primary
benefit of one of your company's cells
the primary benefit has to go to those
other than the contributor which is
yourself
means it has to go to the customer it
has to go the client
so your your vision statement needs to
pass all those tests
you